alors on voit tout de suite accueillir
les invités avec plusieurs jeunes les
adore les bleus a oui elle nous a
préparé un show en plus véronic dicaire
y ait là allez on accueille tout de
suite aux invités juste le temps
d'ouvrir le rideau
c'est véronique dicaire et frédéric
beigbeder
c'est très content nous re à l'essai on
va parler une autre votre actualité
j'ai vu je voudrais pas vous dire il ya
un mec qui vous a mal parlé tout à
l'heure je vais le retrouver voulait pas
nous parler parce que à oui oui sans
vexer ah oui vous est fixé à diouf
exceed espagnol femmes horaires voulait
tendre il a dit de fermer notre gueule
j'ai rien franchement je ne fais pas ça
pour vous justement est alors dans mon
dans ma langue fermer sa gueule ça veut
dire amusez vous
nous avons la nuque
merci il s'occupe de moi comment ça va
mais ronning très bas mais ronnie dessus
content vous nous avez préparé un petit
regret il faut nous faire un petit show
là dans l'émission oui vraiment
c'est tellement content d'avoir faire
des imitations t on est quoi nous faire
une petite imitation d'un cent us pour
nous m non loin la bouche qui veut que
j'imite ce que vous voulez pas parce que
vous allez nous faire tout à l'heure
mais quelqu'un d'autre quand vous me
regarder comme ça parce qu'elle va même
faire des gens autour de la table
moi j'aime bien isabelle quoi c'est vrai
a voulu nous faire isabelle tout à
l'heure isabelle à tout à l'heure elle
voulait faire et sa balle tout de suite
non je peux fumer là tu peux attendre
faites ce que vous voulez c'est un petit
truc à nous chanter là ne servent les
bléquin shawey j'adore bas quand on
chante quoi ce que vous voulez mais on
chante et on chantait judo on chante
quoi céline dion ou sado céline dion
avec les paroles échangées par exemple
adacore voulait c'est vrai vous avez
quoi mais c'est que votre équipe m'a mis
au défi
oui de chance de chanter céline dion
ouais avec les paroles de au bal masqué
alors vous voulez vous voulez un micro
ou véronique je ne sais pas c'est votre
équipe technique idéale aussi bouge pas
à mon avis sinon vous aviez prévu quoi
l'équipe technique
alors là et voilà rien vous avez prévu
de partir chez vous merci merci valve
time ça vous en perdez pas non mais
c'est bon un joseph qui peut la
retourner aux etats-unis aussi mais la
musique est
elle ne peut pas s'arrêter
d'accord
en mai
open jeter on ne peut pas s'arrêter là
nasa
masqué
je te laisser ma carte je te faire faire
du show biz et un autre lesquels nous a
préparé je le sais rien petits trucs sur
les sardines non ils ont revendu une
micro masaya et les parties merci joseph
si joseph regarder le fils du gars de
prison break et de louis de funès
c'est le propre des jolies en vrai
ben c'est quoi ça nommé jeudi qu'à la
télé regarde la télé aussi mais en vrai
c'est mieux regard il n'a pas toute sa
tête il dit il a fait nommer ça fait 50
ans qui fait des uv tous les jours je
fasse erronée vous êtes vous faites ce
que vous voulez moi je suis fan lara
fabian qui chantait dit
m
j'adore pour faire une chanson facile
vous d'abord des parents piles aa
une petite même dit quitteront la tête
pour fuir le feu
ne dansez l'on ressent 5 ou 6 2 6
millions comme tout ensemble pour
changer
samedi
ce les enfants
non
entre
aromates
tu vois jamais est ce à dire
pourquoi
à laquelle bonheur quel bonheur et
maintenant elle est exceptionnelle et
véronique moi je pourrais faire ça
pendant deux heures la regardez
d'ailleurs elle nous apparaît pas d'un
autre truc pour tout à l'heure vous
allez voir la patrie qu'elle nous fera
ça va vous sinon j'attends mais j'ai dit
tout à l'heure tout à l'heure bon
d'accord merci et bien sûr d'autant
d'attention à frédéric beigbeder qui
nous chantera à lui allumez le feu bien
sûr sur l'air du petit bonhomme en
mousse amont fred